can I ask you about a Thomas related
person away who pops up this season pops
up literally I didn't know where oh my
god it was so so stressful I was shocked
when I saw Ashley but then again I
wasn't the cat was out of the bag that
she was gonna show up so everybody was
tearing around everything because we
just assumed you know how can you still
show your face why would you want to you
kind of take a bullet for the team and
have a sit-down talk with her at one of
the times when she showed up it was kind
of difficult because I felt like some of
my advice would register but then she
would kind of revert back to her old
ways so she's a little bit dr. Jekyll
and mrs. Hyde did you have a one-on-one
with her I sure did
how did that go I survived it it wasn't
easy I think I drank a bottle and a half
of wine through the whole thing there
was tension and Shep handled hid because
my last interaction with her I guess oh
right a prostitute I think Ashley he's
like an Escalade
that's not true
I'm even interested to see kind of what
she said when we weren't around her and
she was just with Catherine it was that
learn as scared music I mean luckily you
know nature takes its course with humans
like her - humans I that's what I
referenced I rise because I don't know
what and she's not a real person in ways
she self-destructs why bringing Ashley
background this group we know doesn't
like her she seems super sweet and nice
and bubbly and fun and I hadn't seen her
since all that had gone down with her
following Catherine names and okay bye
we are I found your baby mama it go
right on man and nothing but an egg
donor okay keep walking why is the
standing here now that you know all that
oh I would have hell no I wouldn't have
brought her I think Ashley wanted to
come back this year and try to make
amends because I think she felt bad but
the question is did she really feel bad
was it genuine from the heart or did she
just want to make herself look good
let's just say I'm happy with the end
result of Ashley Jacobs the truth will
come out
he is obsessed she made no bones about
the fact that she was coming for me he
said fire in horizon you're like you are
the same you are the same freakin person
you don't know how to apologize without
doubling down there can you push me so
hard this seems very finite like this is
the end of Ashley Jacobs I mean so I
safe to say Ashley at this point has
shown you who she is and it's not who
you believed her to be no yeah I'm
calling the cops
is she still around here rumor has it
that Ashley is still in Charleston there
have been sightings yes it's like a
Bigfoot yes so are she and Thomas
together right now I think they are and
they aren't though they probably don't
know either and it'll probably always be
that way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]